hey everyone i hope you're all doing
great
welcome to simply loans youtube channel
and today we'll be discussing about the
coding interview questions
we will begin this video with some
conceptual questions about data
structures algorithms
and then move on to discussing the
coding problems that are most commonly
asked to solve in interviews
these questions will help you summarize
every important programming concept
and serve as a perfect preparation
resource for coding interviews
by the end of this video i can assure
you that you will have a proper
understanding of data structure concepts
and you will be able to code the most
common problems asked in interviews
so let's get started with an exciting
video on coding interview questions
before we begin please make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
that bell icon
to never miss an update from simply
learn so i hope i was clear with the
agenda
now let's begin with the top 40 coding
interview questions that you should know
programming interview questions are an
integral part of an interview
for the developer's position no matter
which programming language you master it
is expected that you are familiar with
the fundamental concepts of the
programming
coding skills are always the deciding
factor in any programming interview
we will discuss the top 40 coding
interview questions
you should absolutely know how to crack
in interviews to get your dream job
so without further ado let's get started
so as discussed the first part would be
the conceptual interview questions
and that the first question we have to
face is what is a data structure
so the answer for this question is a
data structure is a storage format
that defines the way the data is stored
organized and manipulated
some popular data structures are arrays
trees
and graphs moving ahead we have our next
question that is what is an array
so basically all the items that an array
stores
are of the same data type it organizes
data so that a related
set of values can be easily sorted or
searched
now followed by an array the next
question we have is about the linked
list
so what is a linked list it is
completely similar to array but there
are some basic differences
like an array a linked list is a linear
data structure in which elements are not
necessarily stored in a continuous
manner so linked list is basically a
sequence of nodes where
each node points to the next node
forming a chain like structure
so followed by the linked list we have
the next question which is based on
stacks
so what exactly is a stack stack is a
linear data structure that performs
operations in a leaf or order
so in a stack elements can only be
accessed starting from the top most to
the bottom element
so followed by stacks we have our next
question which is
what is a lifo so basically lifo stands
for
last in first out so it is a way of
accessing
storing and retrieving data the data
that was stored at the last is extracted
at the first
the next one after lifo is a queue so
what exactly is a queue
q is a linear data structure that
performs operations in a fifo
order so basically fifo is first in
first out in a queue the least recently
added elements are removed first as
opposite to the stack so up next we have
the fifo
so what exactly is fifo fifo stands for
first in first out it is a way of
accessing storing and retrieving data
the data that was stored first is
extracted first
the next question is about the binary
trees so
what exactly are binary trees a binary
tree
is an extension of linkedlist data
structure
where each node has two children
binary tree has two nodes at all the
times a left node
and a right node so these left and right
nodes for the top node are known as
children of the top node
next we have as recursion so what is
recursion
recursion refers to a function calling
itself based on a terminating condition
it uses last and first start
functionality and therefore
makes use of the stack data structure
followed by recursion we have the oops
so what is the oops concept
oops stands for object-oriented program
programming system
a paradigm that provides concepts such
as objects
classes inheritance polymorphism
encapsulation
etc so what are the concepts introduced
in oops
so the following concepts are introduced
in oops they are
object class inheritance polymorphism
abstraction and encapsulation now we
will discuss each one of them in a bit
more detail
so we will begin with object a real
world entity having a particular state
and a behavior
is called as an object it can be defined
as an instant of a class
so next we have the class a logical
entity that defines the blueprint
from which an object can be created or
instantiated is called as a class
so basically class is a blueprint which
we use to create an
object so followed by classes and
objects we have the
inheritance a concept that refers to an
object acquiring all the properties
and behaviors of a parent object is
called as inheritance
so basically inheritance provides code
reusability
so followed by inheritance the next
important concept we have is the
polymorphism
so polymorphism is a concept that allows
the task to be performed in different
ways
in java we use method overloading and
method overriding to achieve
polymorphism
followed by polymorphism we have the
abstraction
a concept that hides the internal
details of an application and shows only
the functionality
is called as abstraction in java we use
abstract classes and interface to
achieve abstraction
the last one is the encapsulation
encapsulation is a concept that refers
to wrapping of code
and data together into a single unit so
basically
every code we have in the java will have
data members and data manipulating
methods so encapsulation is a basic
concept that
brings them together and binds them as a
single unit
so followed by oops concepts the next
important question that we will be
facing is about
the binary search tree so explain binary
search tree
a binary search tree stores data in such
a way that it can be retrieved very
efficiently
next the left subtree contains nodes
both
keys are less than that of the node's
key value the right
sub tree contains nodes those keys are
greater than or equal to
the node's key value followed by that
the next question we have is
the doubly linked list so what exactly
are doubly linked lists
the doubly linked lists are special type
of linked list in which
traversal across the data elements can
be done in both directions
this is made possible by having two
links in which
one of the node will be connected to the
next upcoming node
and the other link is connected to the
previous node
so followed by the doubly linked list
the next important question we have is
the graph
so what exactly is a graph a graph is
one type of data structure that contains
a set of ordered pairs
so these ordered pairs are also referred
as edges or arcs and
arcs are used to connect nodes where
data can be stored or retrieved
so followed by this we have our next
question that is called as the
difference between
linear and non-linear data structures so
the first difference is the linear data
structure in which data elements are
adjacent to each other
and the non-linear data structure is a
structure in which each element can
connect to
two adjacent data elements
followed by that the next difference is
examples of linear data structure are
the arrays linked list stacks and others
like queues
and examples for non-linear data
structures are trees and graphs
followed by that the next question is of
what is a dq
so dq is a double ended queue and this
is a structure in which elements can be
inserted or removed from either end
followed by that we have our next
question which says the difference
between the stack and an
array so stack follows a lifo pattern it
means that the data axis follows a
sequence in which the last data to be
stored
is the first element to be extracted
next we have the array
arrays on the other hand do not follow a
particular order and instead can be
accessed
by referring the indexed element within
the array
followed by that the next question is
which sorting algorithm is the best
there are many types of sorting
algorithms like quicksort bubble sort
balloon sort radix sort merge sort etc
and no algorithm can be considered as
the best
or the fastest because each is designed
for a specific type of data structure
where it performs the best and
our 19th question is how does variable
declaration affect
memory so the amount of memory can be
allocated or reserved depends on the
data type
being stored in that variable for
example if a variable is declared to be
integer type then 32 bits of memory
storage will be reserved for that
variable
so the 20th question is what are dynamic
data structures
so dynamic data structures are the data
structures that expand and contract as
the program runs
it provides a flexible means of
manipulating data because it can adjust
according to the size of the data
so these were the conceptual based
questions so far we discussed now
next we will move ahead into the
programming interview questions
so at first we have how do you reverse a
string
in java so you can see on my screen we
have a code segment that is capable of
reversing a string so basically you
declare a string then take the length of
that string
loop through the characters of the
string and add these characters in the
reverse order then
print the resultant string next we have
how do you determine if a string is a
palindrome or not
so for that particular question we have
a code segment which is capable
to reverse the string and check if it is
a palindrome or not and accordingly
provide the result
so a string is a palindrome when it
stays the same on the reversing order
of characters in that string it is
achieved by reversing the original
string first and then
checking if the reverse string is equal
to the original string
or not followed by that we have the 23rd
question that says find the number of
occurrences of a string character
in a string so the following code
segment is capable to find that
particular task
and to find the number of occurrences of
loop through the string and
search for that character in every
iteration whenever it is found
then the count will be updated followed
by that the 24th question is
find if the given two strings are
anagrams or not
two strings are considered as anagrams
if they contain similar group of
characters in
varied sequence so for finding out if
two strings are anagrams or not we have
the code segment on the right part of my
screen right now
so basically you declare a boolean value
that tells the end of the two strings
are anagrams or not
then first check the length of the both
strings if they are same or not
then if they are not same then they are
not anagrams if they are same
then they are anagrams like they might
be a chance of being
the two strings as anagrams and followed
by the next step is
convert both the strings to character
arrays then sort them out
and finally check the sorted arrays if
they are equal or not if they are equal
then print
their anagrams and if they are not equal
then you should print
not anagrams the next 25th question is
how do you calculate the number of
wobbles and consonants in a string
so you can see on my screen i have a
code segment which will be capable of
counting bubbles and consonants in a
string
so look through the string so that's the
first step followed by that
increase the vocal variable by 1
whenever the character can be found as a
vowel
using the if condition otherwise
increment the consonant variable
finally print the values of both the
vowels and consonants count
the next important question we will be
facing in the coding interview is
how do you get matching elements in an
integer array
so for that we have a code segment on my
screen right away
now the steps for that are declare an
array nest a couple of loops
and compare the numbers with the other
numbers in the array and finally
print the matching elements whenever
found so next we have this 27th question
that says
code bubbles out algorithm you don't
have to code the entire bubble sort
algorithm
what you can do is just write the code
segment which has a logic for it
so that is currently on my screen right
now so what you basically do is declare
an array
so next what you do is nest a couple of
loops and compare the numbers in that
array and then the array will be sorted
in the ascending order by replacing the
elements if found in any other order
28th question is code the insertion sort
algorithm so this is completely similar
approach what we followed for the bubble
sort you just have to write the
code segment of logic so the steps will
be
first the element in the array is
assumed to be sorted
take the second element and then store
it separately
in key now the first two elements are
like sorted
take the third element and then compare
it with the elements in the left of it
the process goes on until the array is
sorted
so next we have the 29th question how do
you reverse an
array so you can see on my screen we
have a code segment that says how to
reverse an array
loop till the half length of the array
next we have to replace the numbers
corresponding to the indexes from the
starting to the end
followed by that we have the 30th
question where we have to find
a way to swap two numbers without the
third variable
so this type of interview question will
be asked most number of times to the
beginners
most frequently now the solution for
that has been written on my screen right
away you can check out that
and the steps to be followed are declare
two variables and initialize them with
the values make
b the sum of both the numbers then
subtract the sum
that is the b from a so a
is now swapped lastly subtract a
from the sum b so b is now also swapped
next we have the 31st question which
says print a fibonacci series using
recursion
so for that we have a code segment which
can print a fibonacci series on my
screen right now
so the code on my screen can be used to
print the fibonacci series
so basically what are fibonacci numbers
so the fibonacci numbers are the numbers
in the following integer sequence 0
1 1 2 3 5 8 13 21 and so on
they can be calculated using the
mathematical formula used in the
fibonacci recursive
function the next question you'll be
facing is how do you find the factorial
of an integer
so we have the code segment on my screen
which can perform
the factorial of an integer operation so
the factorial is a function that
multiplies
a number by every number below it for
example
factorial of 5 is 5 into 4 into 3 into 2
into 1 which is equal to 120.
so recursive function multiplies the
number until it reaches
1. the next one is how do you reverse a
linked list
so for that we have the code segment on
my screen right away you can please
check it out and try it so if you can
find out if it can reverse a linked list
or not
so the steps to be done for that are
declare a linked list first
then add elements to that linked list
apply the descending iterator method to
the linked list
and then they should reverse the order
of the elements in the linked list
the 34th question is how do you
implement the binary
search so for that we have the code
segment right on my screen you can check
that out
and the steps to be followed are
mentioned in the code segment so the
binary search divides the array into
half in every iteration step until it
finds the
element it works on sorted arrays since
it compares the values of adjacent
elements and then calculates the middle
number
if the value of low becomes greater than
high
at any point it means the element is not
present in the list
so this is how the binary search
basically works followed by that we have
the 35th
question which says find the second
largest number in the array
so you can see we have a code segment on
my screen to find it out
so the steps to be followed are loop
through the array if the value of i is
greater than the highest
store the value of i in the highest and
store the value of highest in the second
highest variable
so now let's move ahead to the 36th
question
how do you remove all occurrences of a
given character from the input string
so we have a simple small code segment
on my screen right away
so that code segment can be used to
remove all the occurrences of a given
character
from an input string so what you can do
is use the
built in string method that is replace
to replace
a character with any other character
including symbols
and white spaces so followed by that we
have our 37th question
so that is showcase inheritance with the
help of a program
so we have a small course limit on my
screen to
showcase the one of the major object
oriented programming
method that is inheritance so the class
cat inherits the property
color from class animal by extending the
parent class animal
this way a class cat can have more
parent classes if it wishes to inherit
their properties as well
so next question that is the 38th
question is
explain overloading and overriding with
the help of a program
so this is a major question which is
asked many number of times
most frequently for the beginners and
sometimes even the experienced
candidates cannot
escape this question so first we'll
discuss overloading
when a class has two or more methods
with the same name
they are called as overloaded methods so
you can see a code segment on the right
side part of my screen right away
so this is an example for overloading
next we will discuss the overriding
so next we will discuss the overriding
so when a superclass method is also
implemented in the child class then it's
a clear case of overriding
so on the right side part of my screen
you can see a code segment
where a child class is extending the
base class method
which is print name now followed by that
we have the 39th question
that is check if the given number is
prime or not
so you can see a code segment on my
screen which determines if the given
number is a prime number or not
so the steps to be followed to find if a
given number is prime or not r
use if statements to check for each
condition
separately if the number is 0 or 1 it
cannot be prime
if the number is 2 it is prime if the
number is
and finally the third condition you need
to take care of is
if the number is indivisible by other
numbers
then it is prime so basically prime
numbers are divisible by 1 or itself
if any other number is capable to divide
the number then it is
not a prime number now the last question
in the list is how do you sum all the
elements in an array
so for that we have a code segment right
on my screen please
check it and try to run it and that's
the best way to learn
so the steps to be followed are use the
loop to iterate through the array
and keep adding the elements in that
array and finally you will get the sum
of the elements in the array and you can
just print this sum at the last
so with that as you prepare for your
upcoming job interview we hope these
coding questions
have provided more insight into what
types of questions you are likely to be
asked
and with that we have come to an end of
this video on coding interview questions
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
about any topics covered in this video
please feel free to ask in the comment
section below our team of experts will
be happy to solve all your queries
thank you for watching stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here